big nose really really really big news
at breaking today I'm super excited
y'all I'm hosting the Grammy Awards
Alicia Keys is set to host the 61st
annual Grammy Award it's gonna be so
fresh total I'm thrilled it's like you
know a little bit of a second home to me
and I feel so blessed to be able to be
able to be coming now
just in support of so many amazing
people that are honored especially so
many women that are honored that are
gonna be celebrated that night when I
heard that news and just how many women
are nominated and being honored it just
felt like come on I want to set that
party off for us that night you know I
just want to set it off I want to
celebrate I want to be the one that
really just continues to reach out to
the people that I love and admire and my
friends and just be able to create an
amazing energy so I'm loving the 15-time
Grammy Award winner will take the stage
Sunday February 10 and revealed she's
not asking for advice from past hosts
James Corden or LL Cool J I'm ecstatic
to be a woman and artist writer or
producer or creator just like all the
people in that audience and that's what
makes the Grammys so it's so amazing you
know it's like you get to be honored by
your peers by other creative people that
you admire and so it's that type of
celebration it's just there's no there's
nothing like it
big shouts to to her big shouts to do a
leap big shouts to Brandi Carlile big
shouts to just you know Janelle is up
there I'm ecstatic about that I mean big
shots to Carly I mean there's so many
just unique individual women who are
their own producers their own writers
their own creators you know that they
give us the energy that we're looking
for so I'm really excited to just
celebrate us you know it's our
sisterhood so we doing it come on ladies
there's so many people I'm so excited to
see I'm excited to see them perform I'm
excited to see them win you know I'm
excited to see them just be glorified
you know what I mean but I think I'll
probably have like that anticipation
excitement just because that's how I
feel when I go out there in the world
you know you just you feel anticipation
but the nerves I don't think it's gonna
be a nerve thing it's gonna be a vibe
thing and when it comes to her approach
to hosting music's biggest night I'm not
telling you these surprises I'm not
telling you nothing but yes it's gonna
be over vibe
we're gonna have an amazing time I think
you have to tune in and find out
[Applause]
[Music]